welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and with spiderman no way home days
away new last-minute trailer footage is
giving us unseen looks at peter parker
and doctor strange's critical choices in
the final battle as well as this movie's
villains and just how confused these old
men are what happened to the ducks there
used to be ducks on this river am i
supposed to eat all these bread crumbs
myself okay i will i am gonna break down
all the new details that you might have
missed let's roll the first clip all
right parker you ready
[Music]
do it
exclusively in cinemas oh my god peter
palpatine confirmed guilty we've seen
some of this footage before strange
asking peter if he's ready seems to be
coming from the earlier spell that peter
tampers with that initially causes the
multiverse crisis however peter's saying
do it followed by doctor strange casting
his magic are new shots from the final
battle of this film peter is wearing his
gold integrated suit and has a roughed
up face doctor strange now casts his
golden runes that orbit him in front of
the crumbling sky that spills into the
purple abyss beyond actually our friend
mt has a great video coming out that
explains the significance of that purple
light but then the promo editing syncs
strange's spell with the shot of the
mirror dimension shattering which is
also a very cool shot but i think it
more likely takes place earlier in the
film when peter initially steals that
box and doctor strange encloses him
inside the mirror dimension and freaks
him out with all the train cars we
actually also see a new shot of the
moment peter hits that train car which
seems to come at the end of his big
tumble down through the donuting city
and now we can see he descends into
central park where the train comes out
of a portal at him but here's a very
cool detail i'm pretty sure this part of
central park is the bethesda fountain
which is a circular pond that at the
center of it has the angel of the water
statue that borders the larger lake of
central park except if you look closely
at that statue i'm pretty sure the angel
has been replaced with something else no
angel wings instead an arm reared back
as if for a punch now in real life a
statue of captain america was erected in
brooklyn in 2016 but we also know in
this film new york's famous statue of
liberty is being remodeled so that lady
liberty is carrying a giant captain
america shield so this angel of the
water statue may also be swapped out
with some avenger the city wants to pay
tribute to iron man vision black widow
or another cap capcap cap but back to
peter in strange strange's runes are
similar to the ones he cast in his
initial spell in his dungeon that caused
this crisis but with some major
differences the ones in his first spell
look simpler like brush script hastily
scribbled down and shorthand by contrast
these runes have more of an outline and
a structure more authoritative decisive
they actually share a similar typeface
with the runes wanda maximoff cast in
one division during her final duel with
agatha harkness wanda just cast two of
those it looked like in order to prevent
agatha from casting her magic in this
given space and trick her into opening
herself up to being drained of her magic
doctor strange appears to be using a lot
more runes but they have the same
glowing bold outline structure so this
now raises the question what is peter
asking strange to do when he says do it
you know as i'm going through all these
details sometimes once i found a detail
i just feel an instinct that i want to
blow it up to let myself know i'm done
with it well now i get to do that
because the mechs are here mech arena is
a killer new five versus five mech
shooter with tons of awesome game modes
maps mechs weapons and fast-paced
competitive gameplay the rush of good
balance competitive play is built in
from the first play session and you
immediately get the sense that skill
actually matters if you want a shooter
where you can compete win and get
recognized you're gonna love this mech
arena has a massive event running now
until december 14th to raise one hundred
thousand dollars for charity by
destroying one billion mechs just
install the completely free game on ios
or android using the link in the
description box if you download now from
our link you'll get 50 000 credits five
gold crates and a unique event skin once
you're in sign up for the event in game
start playing and go make some mayhem
for a great cause that great cause is
ablegamers a non-profit that works with
the gaming industry to make video games
more accessible for people with
disabilities and to give them access to
the community and the fun that video
games provide as the whole mech arena
community hits milestones mecha arena
will hand out prizes in-game loot and
charity money and choose 10 lucky
winners for the grand prize a chance to
compete in the championship and pilot a
real mech and mech arena had a cool live
event last weekend at santa monica pier
off-screen producer zach got to interact
with a news crew that was covering the
event use the link in the description to
download mech arena for free and start
destroying mechs for a good cause going
by the one division logic wanda's spell
was designed for her to create a pocket
barrier within her westview pocket
dimension in which only wanda could
control the magic that occurred within
that inner inner circle if doctor
strange is doing a similar thing he
could be containing all the multiversal
madness that is breaking this universe
into one pocket dimension sequestered
from the outer world we saw doctor
strange and the watcher pull a similar
move in what if when zola ultron and
killmonger infinity dueled over the
infinity stones and both threatened the
fabric of the multiverse strange in the
watcher contained the destruction within
its own pocket dimension that was also
within the pocket dimension of strange
supremes self-exile so peter might be
saying do it imprison me with these
other threats in a pocket dimension away
from everyone i love in order to protect
them if that is how doctor strange
temporarily fixes this crisis i don't
expect it to be a lasting solution
neither for this movie nor for what if
because pocket dimensions are meant to
be broken but let's move on to the
return of the villains vignette recently
released in which alfred molina william
defoe and jamie foxx talk about their
character's returns and pretend lizard
and sandman aren't in this let's take a
look doc picks up where he left off what
have you done with my machine he's
looking for revenge do you want to play
games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
interesting so doc ock truly will return
from his final moments in the boathouse
from 2004's spider-man 2 his machine
referring to his fusion device in which
he used tritium to spark a fusion
reaction to try to create renewable
energy that was his maniacal obsession
in the third act of that film but rather
than being warped from the moment he was
drowning doc ock must have been taken
from a few minutes before that because
when he decided to drown the fusion
reaction in the river at that point doc
had his humanity restored evidenced by
his claws red lights turning back white
but here in no way home the red lights
are back on the claws meaning that the
warp transference moment must have
occurred before peter electrocuted dock
and before tevia forced his claws to
listen to me now similarly it looks like
wilma defoe's green goblin whose thick
ass now hops on his glider in the feast
lobby before tossing a pumpkin grenade
at peter was also taken from a moment of
his peak cruelty when he considered life
to be a zero-sum game in which
spider-man had to be killed a zero-sum
game that he forced peter to engage in
by making him choose between mary jane
or i suffer the children when i broke
down the films of the raimi trilogy back
in summer 2020 my favorite detail that i
found in the 2002 film was that random
terrifying jump scare shot where goblin
screams at the audience
[Music]
which if you look closely at the shot
there is a creepy second goblin lurking
in the background for whatever reason
wouldn't it be amazing if spider-man no
way home could justify that bizarre
glitch in the matrix as the moment the
raimi vs reality was glitching to
transport one of these goblins over in
the mcu hey if you want to support this
channel check out some of our great
merch options at noxersmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you